All right.
So let me start by
motivating IPyShiny
with this interactive
web application.
So in Core Shiny itself,
we have the ability
to only render like a
few different things
like images, and
plots, and text.
Like some very
basic core utilities
for rendering Python objects.
Let me mention this is also
very experimental at this point.
And partially the
reason why it's
in a separate
package at this point
is we've been experimenting
with the ability
to render IPywidgets with Shiny.
So if you're not already
familiar with IPywidgets
it provides this foundation
for Python developers
to create a Python package that
wraps a JavaScript library.
A library like leaflet for
creating interactive maps.
And provide an
interface in Python
that people can then use
that Python package to create
these interactive
data visualizations
inside of Jupyter.
So traditionally, the main
platform for using IPywidget's
Jupyter.
But we've provided
this wrapper to allow
you to write the
same IPywidgets code
and just get that into
Shiny in the way that
makes the most sense to you.
So this is a motivating example
where I have some data here.
This is showing
a superZIP score.
And these superZIP
scores are really
like some combination of
percent college educated,
median income, and
I think population
for each ZIP code in the US.
So you can go to this
dropdown, and instead
of looking at some combination
of income and education,
essentially, you can
look at just education.
So you can see compared
to this overall score,
percent college educated
is a lot more highly densed
in the Northeast in the US.
And then you can see
median income is actually
maybe more highly correlated
with this overall score.
It's at least more
wide spread out.
Basically, three
different main measures
that we're looking at here.
And then this is a density
plot of the overall score
for all of the US essentially.
So you can see
this overall score,
there's a pretty high
concentration around 0 to 20.
And same similar for college
but it's more pronounced.
And pretty similar
distribution for income.
And then this is the
log of the population.
If I didn't take the
log here it'd be super--
you'd basically just see
a straight line up here
and then a very long tail.
And the point of having these
density plots here is this
is programmed in such a
way that I can zoom in
on this application.
And these density
plots will update.
Whenever I change the
bounding box of this map,
I will recompute the
density of these things
conditional on just the
ZIP codes within this area.
So as I zoom in
here to the DC area,
you can see the in
bound's density here,
there's a much higher density
of very high overall scores
in the DC area.
And that's really a combination
of the percent college
educated and the
income both being
much higher in these
areas, as well as
a higher population I guess.
Population density I should say.
And then if you want to get more
detailed into what specifically
is in this view, there's
this Details tab over here
that tells me there's
123 ZIP codes currently
in that bounding box.
And amongst those 123 ZIPs,
23% are considered superZIPs.
Which just means their score
is above a certain threshold
and their mean income
is nearly $100,000.
The mean population is
a little over 10,000,
and the mean college
educated is nearly 40%.
And then if I wanted--
if I had other data
about these ZIP codes,
I can see other information
here like their relative rank
amongst all of the ZIP
codes and stuff like that.
And this is also hooked
up to another map where
if I want to click on
a particular County
and see exactly where
that County is I
can zoom in on this map
and I can see where this--
sorry.
ZIP code is actually located.
And this is currently a bug.
When I click on this pop
up the table goes away,
but hopefully that will
get fixed sometime soon.
Where I could click on
this marker as well to see,
basically, that same
information displayed again.
So the repo's name is ipshiny.
If you go to the
GitHub page, it will
have some information
on how to install it
and a quick overview
on how to use it.
There's a couple
of different ways
you can actually render
an IPwidget with IPyShiny.
And the first use
that it goes over
is-- it should feel
really intuitive
if you are already an IPwidget
user instead of a Shiny user.
So hopefully most
of the audiences
in that former group where you
want to always within a Shiny
app create your user interface.
And in that user interface,
use this output widget
which comes from IPyShiny.
And like any other
UI component, you
want to give it an
ID that you'll then
reference on the server.
And inside of the
server function,
the recommended
way to do this is
to first initialize the widget
object when the server first--
server function first executes.
So this will only run once.
We'll be initializing the
map just once with a center
location and a zoom level.
And then once you're
ready, you want
to call register
widget with the ID that
should match this ID on the
user interface to basically say,
I have my widget object here
that I want you to perform
like an initial draw of--
for the application.
And then for all of
the other updates,
you're actually
performing side effects.
You're not like redrawing--
recreating the
widget from scratch,
you're essentially just mutating
properties on that widget.
So it's a little bit different
if you're coming from a Shiny
world, where we
essentially reinitialize
and redraw a widget
every time we want
to update it using our code.
But here, we will register,
essentially, side effects.
So we haven't seen
this yet from Shiny,
but this is a decorator that
comes from the Shiny reactive
sub package.
So we saw reactive calc before.
Where this is-- a calc,
you might remember,
wants you to return a value.
So it reads some other reactive
values and then returns
a reactive value.
But with side effects, this
also can read reactive values,
but you're not
going to be calling
this function for
a return value,
you're going to be calling this
function for its side effects.
So when I say reactive
effect, I don't really
need to give this a
name because Shiny isn't
going to put this anywhere.
So I can just use this
underscore and define
a function.
And then I will read
the zoom input value,
which is coming from
our Shiny input slider
up here at the zoom.
And that is going to then--
what this is
essentially saying is
whenever the slider
changes, update
the map's zoom attribute.
So map.zoom is like
an IPywidget property
that will be mutating every time
the value of this zoom input
value changes.
All right.
So we just went
over the side effect
that allows me to change
this input slider,
to change the zoom
level on the map.
But what if I wanted to go the
other way in the sense of I
can also use this control that's
directly attached to the widget
instance on the IPywidget?
If I wanted to zoom in this way.
What if I wanted
to, essentially,
have that bidirectional
communication of changing
the zoom on the map,
update the slider as well?
So in order to do something
like this where you're
kind of treating the IPywidget
like an input control,
to then update some other
thing on your user interface.
Then you want to use
this helper function,
that again comes
from IPyShiny, to--
this reactive read
essentially allows
me to read this zoom property on
the map object in the same way
that I would read like
in a true Shiny input
value like this input.zoom.
By using this reactive read here
inside of this reactive side
effect, that will
ensure whenever
the zoom property
changes on this map,
this function is going
to re-execute and perform
side effects.
So I'll get the zoom
level from the map
here, and use that to
inform this function that's
coming from Shiny to
update the slider.
So this is coming from
the UI sub package
to say, update this
slider with an ID of zoom,
and update its value to whatever
the zoom level is on the map.
Right?
So this is like--
it changes from the
slider to the map.
And if you want to go the other
way from the map to the slider,
you could do
something like this.
And then this last
part here is basically
to get this text up here
showing the current latitude
and longitude on the bounding
box of this map, which
will change whenever
this zoom level changes.
But I can also pan on the map
to get a different bounding box
with different
latitude and longitude.
If I wanted to do
something like this,
this is available on the
maps bounds attribute.
So normally, if you wanted to
read this property in a Jupyter
context, you would just type
out map.bounds, and then
enter on your console,
and that would give you
the current bounds
But we want to
re-actively read this.
Whenever the bounds
change, we want
this output to get invalidated
and basically, re-execute.
So that's why we use
the reactive read here.
And then from this
bounds I'm just
getting the latitude and
longitude in a more usable way.
And then returning a string
with the current latitude
and longitude and
rendering that as text.
Yeah, that basically
kind of covers
the core of what you
would need to do something
like coordinate other controls
with a widget in terms
of keeping its state in
sync with other things
in your application.
And also keep in mind that if
you are coming from our Shiny
world, and this doesn't make
a whole lot of sense to you,
or it's a foreign programming
paradigm that you're not
so keen on using, we
do also, in IPyShiny,
provide a more render
text like interface.
You can initialize widgets
inside of a reactive context.
So there might be
situations where you really
do want the sum parameter that
goes into initializing a widget
to come from a reactive value.
Before, we just had a
hard coded value of 4.
But if you just
needed your slider
to redraw the map for
instance every time
you change the slider,
you could do something
like this, which would
reinitialize and redraw
from scratch that map object.
Which if that redrawing
is relatively cheap,
that can be a totally
fine way to approach how
to render widgets with Shiny.
And again, this is going
to feel like a little bit
more natural in some
cases for Shiny users
because you're not having
to deal with side effects.
And we generally recommend
avoiding side effects
as much as possible, because
they can make your application
logic harder to reason about.
Yeah this other option
is available to you,
but to really highlight a
situation where you do really
want the side effects is maybe
an example like this, where
I'm using plotly to render
a scatterplot with say
10,000 or maybe more points.
Don't worry too much
about this code.
This code is just fitting
a linear regression
to 10,000 different
random x-coordinates
and y-coordinates.
And then I'm going to create
a scatterplot down here
using plotly.
But really the key part here is
I'm using this register widget
way of basically doing all of
the work ahead of time to say,
here's my scatterplot, I know
that this thing isn't going
to need to be redrawn, so
I'm going to initialize
with the scatterplot, register
it to do that initial draw,
and then I will basically
register the side
effect to happen.
Whenever I click this
Show fit button here,
which is tied to this
checkbox, then I just
want to basically toggle the
visibility of this fitted line
that I've added here inside
of the figure widget object.
Right, so the scatterplot is
actually two different pieces.
One the actual markers
is the black dots
here for the
scatterplot, but then,
I've also layered
on a fitted line
that thankfully with like
the way plotly is set up,
you can then mutate
like the visibility
of that specific line traces,
what plotly would call this.
So if you tried to do something
like this where instead imagine
you were creating this
figure widget object
inside of a render widget
context, every time you--
every time the show
fit value changed
you would have to
reinitialize and redraw
a ton of different points.
And you would get a bit
of lag because every time
you click it has to
redo all of that work.
So yeah, it's kind
of a line that people
will have to walk in the
sense that like this is really
easy and quick to get started
with something displaying
inside of Shiny.
But if you're in a
situation where you really
need performant
updates, other outputs
don't depend on
your widget state,
and it's really
convenient to initialize.
Like, this is a handy way to go.
But in the case where
you need performance,
this is going to
be really useful.
So--